all right dude David Denham we're
immersion where you grow reserve New
Mexico New Mexico yes and tell me what
family you grow up with both your
parents I grew up with adopted parents
and I lived lived in a small village in
the middle the forest everything is far
away but uh is that grew up had very
very troubled experience when I was
little my parents is to neglect me and
leave me inside the broom with nothing
and I didn't need it all Lucent drink
piss off the bottle to survive my dad
hit me with board like that metal on the
back I started getting into now to jail
the age of 13 all the way to the age of
17 because uh I couldn't really deal
with the pain and abuse I was going
through with my parents when I was 17 I
started striving to look for my adopted
or my logical mother and when I found
her I was with her a week Carter doing
heroin in the room it she kicked me off
the streets that I've been homeless for
seven months but when I was
my little kid it was hard especially for
me because I grew up out the country I
didn't grow up in the city but you know
I started trying to change my life
around but I still still have the
memories but I try to move on holiday 18
you're 18
yeah 18 and a half I've been on the
streets for seven months so you were
staying with your mom
recently I was I got off the years
probation I stayed with my grandmother
in Oklahoma and got a greyhound out from
Oklahoma to New Mexico because I moved
from New Mexico there when I got out of
jail and I was with my mother for one
week ever since then
so I hitchhiked they shocked all the way
from reserved in Mexico to here but when
I was up went back out to Oklahoma after
after my mother kicked me out I you know
went back to Oklahoma and my grandmother
was you know trying to explain to me
like I know got trouble passed and stuff
like that but move on
you know so of course I came out here to
Los Angeles for the dream but I still I
still go every day
just trying to hang in there are you
using any drugs etre recently I'm not
gonna lie yes I I've done drugs quite
quite a bit but I'm trying to mellow
myself away from it but drugs of use pop
xanies at least pop like three of them
at a time
good I smoke weed because it helps me
out yeah I'm kind of a drinker but and
uh I try to stay away from meth and
heroin if anything but yeah I have done
meth and I've done it that's why well
you
right now I'm pretty much stranded at a
point where I can't make anything I've
went around places around here
either there's two things either I go
back to my home state or I stay here to
try to make a living out here in
California I don't want to end up like
to the point where I'm dirty 24/7 so I
try to keep myself clean as possible
I get any showers I can take any clothes
I can get then I do what I can do really
I sleep anywhere I could find it's clean
not [ __ ] this on the later in time I
don't have a tent I don't have any
equipment doing blowing stuff I have is
this right here
yep I had a 260 pounds of that before
well so your relationship with your
foster parents is not great but it never
it never really was Greek it was one day
they're cool the next day they're pissed
off and my mother well my mother pissed
got pissed off she was doing nice over
the countertop of me know my my dad
worked in freeport-mcmoran suit for 21
years he'd come home from work beat the
[ __ ] out of me then yeah
and what city relationship with your
biological mom is no better
well why bother mom I haven't got to
know her that well she kicked me out
after one week of knowing my adopted
mother is now trying to convince me of
all kinds of stuff you know it's kind of
hard to trust her after the stuff that I
went through years since ages six
did you finish high school no I was
pulled out at ninth grade by my parents
there was a lawsuit against the school
because my dad was trying to make
millions off of suing the school he's
using me as an advantage
do you have an ID I don't have an ID
don't have Social Security all that's
been stolen that's why I want it around
my stuff I've tried to keep an eye on
him because out here peoples are too
jacked stuff for me yeah I got a few
left but I don't see him that much I got
one friend that I call a true friend is
because he's he helped me out recently
when I was in New Mexico but you know I
finished like 7000 miles this year total
for 2019 anyways but you know I'm
yelling but I've got to the point where
you know I did a lot of drugs and
alcohol on my teens when I was applying
it now I'm getting old it just feels
like it's getting too old like I don't
really wanna you know mess with that
stuff anymore
so I've been trying to keep myself a
little bit sober off a lot of it just
smoke weed you know the reason why I
smoke weed cuz I have serious PTSD my
PTSD
flashbangs will come in when I see
something that reminds me something to
happen to me was the most traumatic the
most traumatic was uh when I was little
my mother when I was taking a bath she
would uh chase me around the house naked
and then beat the [ __ ] out of me she
just called my dad and tell him all
kinds of stuff and he'll come home and
it was hell with him it was a lot more
complicated than most most families when
you talk to Beus my dad used his fists
oh I got so used to it I'm not scared to
die I'm not scared of fighting so I'm
hoping that I'm gonna get my GED and
just kind of get a job you're not I mean
I've been broke I've been broke for a
long time so you know I appreciate you
won't hear here's something but you know
everything I'm telling you is the truth
because the stuff that I went through is
bad and there's some stuff that I don't
want to say on camera if you know what I
mean and I'll kind of give whoever's
watching this at him know how bad it was
and yes I have been bullet I've been
bullwhips that is one of the most
painful painful thing that could happen
to you
mind off my adopted father let's take a
bullwhip go around me like that and wrap
around me and slapped me in the chest
really hard it was so painful I felt
like I was about to just so like these
days when I want to rekt or if I break
my arm or whatever I do that broke my
wrist about two months ago I kind of
like tolerate the pain because I'm so
used to
thank you
you